You are listening to radiolab radio from W. N y.
S. T. E. N. P. R.
Okay. Let us begin. Hello. Hello. And with it,
an unusual encounter which comes from this lady. I'm Susan Schaller.
And where do you want me to start her story? You start off, actually,
it starts kind of abruptly. I was indeed riding a bicycle to high school
and a catering truck hit me
and I was put in the hospital with a concussion.
I was 17 years old and the concussion was bad enough that it slowed my brain
enough that I couldn't read. And so naturally I couldn't go to school,
which sucked for her at 17 I was very much a nerd and I was bored out of my
mind. So Imagine Susan sitting there in the hospital one day,
one of her friends,
friend of mine who is just a little older and had graduated the semester before
me, suggested going to the nearby university and uh,
crashing classes. So basically would you go if your brain was working slowly,
why wouldn't you go swimming? I couldn't read,
but I could listen and I could hear and I, and the person was saying that, oh,
it's a lot better than high school.
And so one day she was at this college just kinda wandering down a random
hallway and I opened the first door on the left.
That was the accident that changed my whole life,
just picking that door at the front of the room. It was this older guy,
he was thin, he was bald and he was tracing shapes in the air with his hands.
It was as if there were pictures being painted in the air and then they
immediately disappeared. Then another picture appeared.
Uh,
I was mesmerized.
Wow.
The professor was signing this class was actually one of the first classes to
teach sign at a regular hearing university ever. I had,
I had also walked into history but didn't know it. Fast forward five years,
Susan now is fluent in sign. She moves to Los Angeles.
It's the late 1970s and I was snatched and put into interpreter training
programs because at that time there were very,
very few interpreters and I found myself in a classroom in a community college
and something called a reading skills class. So she walks into the class,
she's kids all over the classroom making big excited gestures.
One to the other end at the door.
I saw this man holding himself kind of off by himself making his own straight
jacket. She went over to the instructor and she pointed at the guy who, who,
who's that guy over there at me, instructor said,
well he was born deaf. His uncle,
he has this kind of insistent uncle who, who brings him here every day.
We don't know exactly what to do with him though.
And what did this guy look like? He was a beautiful, um, well,
now I know, I don't know if I would have had that in my head at the time,
but a beautiful looking Mayan, you know, high cheekbones and black hair,
black eyes and something about his eyes. He was caught heritage.
He was studying mouth and I, I walked up to him and said, hello,
my name is Susan
and this is where things start to get a little weird.
He looks at her and instead of signing his name,
whatever it was, he brings up his hands and signs right back to her. Hello,
my name is Susan [inaudible].
[inaudible]
Susan, like Shakespeare. There's no, I'm Susan. And he responds, no,
I'm Susan. Everything you said
you tried to say exactly. I call it visual Echolalia, polio,
polio, polio, polio. And I remember thinking,
why is he doing this? I mean, Susan, did he,
did he look like he had some kind of disability or can you [inaudible] um,
he was intelligent.
I wouldn't have been able to answer if you had asked me how can you see
intelligence, but you can actually see intelligence in people's eyes.
He was just missing something to copy me meant that he didn't really know what I
was doing and that's when it occurred. This man doesn't have language
[inaudible]
at wait, how old was this guy? He was 27 years old. And in all that time,
no one had taught him sign language or anything. Well,
he didn't know he was deaf. He was born deaf.
He didn't know there was sound really 27 years, no idea that there was sound.
He could see the mouth moving because he people responding.
He thought we figured all this stuff out visually and he thought,
I must be stupid. So here's the question for our hour.
This is radio lab. I'm Chad, I'm Rod. Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich words,
do words do for them? Are they necessary? Can you live without them?
Can you think without them? Can you dream without them?
Can you hold them up? Can you swim back to the story?
So this man that Susan that we don't actually know his real name,
but when she wrote about him in her book, a man without words,
she called him Ildefonso. They are sitting in the classroom,
she's right there with him. And of course she's wondering
what have you been doing for 27 years? So she thinks, well,
let me see if I can teach them some just basic sign language in interest in case
she takes out a book and makes the sign book, but the sign for book,
it looks like opening up a book.
So he thought I was ordering him to open a book and so he grabbed the book and
he opens because he thought I was asking him to do something.
It was very difficult if I gave him the sign for standing up,
he thought I wanted him to stand up and so I couldn't,
I couldn't have a conversation with them then.
It was the most frustrating thing I've ever done in my life. Wait a second.
How long did this go on for? Well, a weeks. It was weeks. Wow.
Oftentimes when we said goodbye or just left me, couldn't really say goodbye.
I really believe that we wouldn't see each other again.
And I was oftentimes very surprised when he would be sitting there at the table.
And I think sometimes he looked surprised that I showed up.
But after a couple of weeks of him constantly miming copying me,
she had an idea perhaps. So it's just possible that if, uh,
if I died tomorrow, I would have had only one really,
really good thought in my life. And this was it.
I thought I'm going to ignore him.
[inaudible]
I taught an invisible student,
I stopped talking to him and I stopped having eye contact and I set up an empty
chair and then she said she would hold up to this empty chair. A picture of it.
Yeah. Kat.
And I was trying to explain to this invisible student that this creature,
a cat,
so I'd be miming a cat and petting a cat and then I signed the sign for cat.
Then she would hop to the other seat,
the invisible student's seat and pretend to get it. Oh,
I know with my facial expression. Oh, I get it. So you're playing all the parts.
You're both the teacher and the invisible student. That's right.
That's doing all these crazy things. And he just watched me.
He stopped copying her, which was good.
But I do this over and over and over for days and days and days.
And she says he just didn't get it. He was, he looked bored a lot of times.
But one day in the middle of one of these endless pretend student exercises,
something happened. How did the corner of her eye,
she sees him shift his body and he looked.
It's interesting how his body was upright and he looks like something was about
to happen. He looked
to round the room.
This is a 27 year old man and looks around the room as if he had just landed
from Mars. And it was the first time he ever saw anything.
Something was about to tap. His eyes grew wider, she says,
and then wider. And then he slaps his hands on the table.
Oh, everything has a name. [inaudible]
[inaudible]
and then looks at me in this demanding way.
And I signed table and he points to the door and I signed door and he points to
the clock and he points to me and I signed Susan and then
he started crying.
He just collapsed and he started crying.
[inaudible]
what is it that happens in human beings?
When we get symbols and we start trading symbols
[inaudible]
it changes our thinking.
It changes our ideas of Oh is no longer the thing,
a table that we eat on,
but there's something about the symbol table that makes the table look
different.
Ildefonso was in love. He was in love.
It's like everything has a name.
For the first couple of weeks he had this,
this list of names that kept growing and growing paper.
Eagle clock, green eye.
[inaudible] kept copying words for him and hat car. No,
gave him the sign for door. Door door, right? D O r
start praying to see that. Can each try Barre this paper.
Yeah.
Jay was fair treasure and you would pull it out every day and you would lie in
carefully unfolded tiger and you would add to it.
[inaudible] Jay thinking me, add to it.
Land walk down. Name add to it.
Cows, the Blue Wall octopus.
Sorry.
What is it that happens in human beings when we get symbols, symbols.
You know, once you have begun to put words onto things,
you can look at a thing,
say this symbolic sound table and the person opposite you knows that you're
talking about.
But she seems to be saying something deeper though that like when you get the
word for table, uh, suddenly the table,
like this table right here looks different.
Like it's somehow the word changes the world in some fundamental way.
Now, I don't know if that's true about the table thing,
but consider what happens when you put words together. Okay.
When you link them up.
Good. Okay. So I want to tell you about this experiment. Fantastic.
That I learned about from a fellow I talked to sometimes Charles and Charles
Phony, who I'm a psychologist at Durham University in the UK. Fernie, Ho.
And note when I first read about this experiment in Charles's book called a
thousand days at wonder,
it blew my mind out of my nose and onto the book and a little messy.
I never wanted to be with you in the library.
It takes a little journey to get to the mind blowing part, but I'm luckily,
and I'll let Charles explain it. The whole thing happens in a room. Yeah.
You're put into this room which is colored completely white.
The walls are white savings. Why the floors? So it's all white, all white,
everything is white.
And you can tell where you are to the extent that some of the walls are longer
than others. So when you're, we in a rectangle is what you're describing. Yeah.
It's a rectangular room. Are you with me so far? I'm with you so far.
Okay. Just to give you a sense of the baseline conditions here.
Imagine you were a rat in this room. Okay.
And somebody comes along and heights and object in one corner of the room. What?
It can be anything. I mean for rats,
would you use food like a biscuit or something? Yeah, yeah.
Hide a biscuit and one of the four corners in one corner you see it. Okay.
But before you can get to it, they pick you up by your tail,
spin you around a bunch of times. Let me see. You don't know where you are.
You don't know which direction you're facing it.
And then they say right now go find the biscuit. So if you do this with a rat,
what will happen is it'll say, all right,
let me go find the biscuit and it will go to one corner, which looks right.
But of course the room also looks like that.
If you turn around through 180 degrees in face,
exactly the opposite direction cause it's a rectangle.
So they get it right about 50% of the time because corners of rectangles or two
of them are identical. Yeah. All right. So, uh,
who should we get on with this? Because I'm well aware of rectangles.
I just needed to get that out of the way. Cause the cool part is coming up.
So what the experimenters did next is they took one of the four white walls
and he turned to blue.
So imagine this scenario. You're in this room.
We've got these four white walls are rather three walls. One of them is blue,
right? Well now you're not confused anymore. You can,
you can relate everything to the blue wall. You can be like, oh,
the corner with the biscuit whistle left of the blue wall or right of the Blue
Wall. Get to the left. You now have the blue wall as a navigational clue. Yes,
that makes sense. You know, we would all be able to do that.
That's not going to be difficult for us. All right,
we got to the good fight yet. Yeah, it's coming. It's coming.
Turns out though the rats,
he says they're still scoring 50 50 what is this?
If they can't take any notice of the blue wall, even with the Blue Wall,
they're only finding the biscuit 50% of the time. Wait a second.
Can I see color? Yeah. Rants can do color. They do it pretty well. Okay.
They also do left, right? Just fine.
But what they can't do is connect those two bits of information together.
In other words, they can only, well they can do left that they can do,
they can do blue, good blue, but it's, they're both separate.
They can't do left of blue.
These different kinds of knowledge can't talk to each other.
How does anyone know that? I mean,
who would rats have been interviewed for this survey? What? David,
they infer this based on studying the rats.
So the rat doesn't have what doesn't have the neurons, doesn't have the,
why doesn't, he doesn't have the rat can't do it. That's just,
that's all you need to know. And I'm gonna make it weird and right now,
neither can some humans.
I spent the first 10 or 15 years of my scientific life studying creatures who
don't talk yet.
That's Elizabeth Spelke is, she's a psychologist at Harvard.
Quite famous for her work with um, hi once you can hear babies.
And I was interested in, uh,
their abilities in relation to billions of other animals, you know,
if we're going to go to the monkey room. So she began the baby development lab,
which is filled with toys and on any given day,
five or six really tiny kids, six months,
toddlers, two. How old are you? Three and a half. Big Time.
So at a certain point, Elizabeth Spelke,
he decided to build a version of the white room in this lab cause she wondered
if rats have so trouble connecting
the idea of left to blue. What about surely maybe humans,
a self-respecting 18 month old human child will succeed in putting them
together. But no,
what we find is that children behave just like the rats. Just like the rat.
Just like the rats. Just like the retro almost. Yeah. Just like the rats.
Well we don't test them with food. We don't test them with digging.
So in superficial ways, superficial features of the studies are different.
But she says kids like the rats cannot connect to the idea of left to the idea
of blue. They just can't do it. And they can't do it at Warren,
they can't do it. It can't do it at three, four, five.
And we find that those children start performing like adults around six years of
age. No, I'm interested. Good.
Something happens at the ripe old age of six. It is shockingly late, right?
Yeah.
Well something happens at the age of six that suddenly allows the kid to connect
concepts like left concepts like blue. And the question is what? What happens?
Several people have suggested that one candidate for his processors doing this
is language
[inaudible].
What do you mean it's a language? Kids are talking certainly at three, four,
five and six. They're talking like, I'm like, uh, the too much, but they're not.
What they haven't yet started to use is spatial language and particularly the
kinds of spatial language that adults would use in this situation to describe
what they're doing. And somewhere around the age of six,
they start to use phrases like over the blue wall and those aren't just words
that come out of the child's mouth. Liz thinks that inside the child's brain,
what that phrase does is link these concepts together, clink,
and at that moment,
hello,
the child leaves the rats behind
you should that is that she doesn't think that kids have that. What?
Let me put it to you a different way. Okay.
This is my best understanding of what she thinks that her basic idea is that a
child's brain begins is a series of
islands and on one island we over here in the rain,
you've got say color. Can you call that the blue island blue, blue, blue, blue,
blue, blue, blue, blue.
That's the part of you that perceives the color blue way.
On the other side of the brain,
you've got the part of you that perceived spatial stuff like left, left, left,
[inaudible] objects like wall. Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa.
These things are there from the beginning, but they're separate.
Then you get the words left,
Blue Wall and then the child for the first time comes upon the phrase left of
the blue, and in that moment all the islands
come together. It is literally the phrase itself,
she says that creates that internal connection.
Everybody's always talked about how languages,
this incredible tool for communication that allows us to exchange information
with other people so much more richly and effectively other animals can.
But language also seems to me to serve as a mechanism of communication between
different systems within a single mind. There you go.
Wouldn't it be just as possible?
Just listen to me here that the kid's brain is developing some new connections
and what follows then follows from the changes in the rain.
So the words are like an after, after, after, after fact after effect. Yeah.
Well that's a good, that's um, no, no.
And the experimenters actually accounted for that.
What the experiment is did next is that they saw, okay,
if language is adding this extra element, let's try and knock it out.
How would you do that?
Would you like shoot something into their brain that kills the language part or
something?
And it's a much simpler way of doing it in a much more humane thing that you can
do.
What we did is put adults in the room and then she says she gave them an iPod.
They've got headphones on playing through those headphones and someone talking.
Yep.
And their job while they're in the room is to just repeat what the person is
saying.
Continuously listening to speech and repeating it the whole time they were in
there.
Actually a really hard thing to do if you'd have to try and shadowing somebody
speaking. I mean, if you join, can we try it? You go and I'll,
and I'll shadow you. Okay.
[inaudible] start speaking and start speaking now let's say
[inaudible] in my head. That's really hard actually. I saw it. Yeah.
And what that does is it knocks out your capacity to use language for yourself.
Basically battering the words out of the uh, adults head.
Why are they doing this? Again, I really want to see,
like if you blast the words out of somebody's head, what would happen?
Can they find the biscuit?
Will they be able to form that simple thought left of the Blue Wall?
Or will they be like the rats who can't?
And and we actually got very dramatic results.
They went right back to B, not the rats. Wow.
Yeah. [inaudible]
Charles,
what I'm wondering is if language allows you to construct a thought that is so
basic as the biscuit is left of the blue wall,
what is thought without language when I didn't think it's very much at all?
What do you mean?
I'm going to put it in a different way and this involves making quite a
controversial statement. I don't think very young children. Do you think
like think period? Was there a period at the end of that sentence?
I don't think they think in the way that I want to call thinking,
which is a bit of a cheat, but let me see what I mean by thinking. Okay.
If you reflect on your own experience,
if you think about what's going on inside your head as you're just walking to
work or sitting on a subway train,
much of what's going on in your head at that point is actually verbal.
I'm going to suggest that the central thread of all that is actually language
languages, a stream of inner speech.
That's what most of us think of as
well. On the other hand,
what I'm most aware of when I'm reflecting is this stuff that I can't put into
words. I think that he's exaggerating the role of of language here.
Yes. This all really hinges on how you would define thinking.
Yes,
and this would say take a musician like I'll give you my example of Bill Evans.
Here is a form of thought
[inaudible].
It carries you through
[inaudible]
definite sequence of phrases, feelings,
emotions, changes,
[inaudible]
and there are no words,
but there's something that we get access to when we gain a full natural language
that we can use, not only to communicate with other people, but with ourselves.
We have to Shapiro's test, test, test, test, test.
This language is fundamentally a competent tutorial system.
As we hit up the steps here, what is this? This is that,
and we're going to Columbia University. See,
we'd gotten interested in the last thing that they spoke.
He said about language being a cognitive aerial thing system, right?
And that led us to Columbia. Here's the deal. Seven minutes later,
which is you have words now. You have words in combination now.
Now you can play with the combination and that is you're here just us three
then, right? It's just a straight good opens up
a kind of an infinity head to foot now as he total gills,
hardly trip with blood are fathers, mothers, daughters,
sons baked in and pasted with the parching streets,
the lended Tyrannus and damn the light to their viral murders.
This is Shakespeare.
When I sat in middle school and they gave a Shakespeare roasted and wrath in
fire and this or size it with coagulate goals,
I was completely confused and I felt stupid. I said,
can you just introduce yourself? James Shapiro, I'm a,
he is a Shakespeare scholar obviously at Columbia University where I've taught
for 25 years and one reason he says that Shakespeare can be confusing is that
often Shakespeare behave not so much like a writer,
but more like a like a chemist combining elements.
He's taking words and he's shoving them together,
smashing them together if you will,
and combining sometimes these word experiments, they didn't go so well. Yes,
the princes or Gellis. Oculus has no,
it goes to me. What does it mean you got me? I mean, I should know. I told him,
look what he did just by adding a little prefix and
there's so many words that we're now familiar with, unnerving. You know,
we all know what that means, but nobody had heard unnerving, unaware,
uncomfortable. He made up uncomfortable.
He was the first to use that word on a stage, right?
An earthly on hand and dress on educated ungoverned meeting Galeana published
something that's near and dear to me. Public, unsolicited.
Unswayed unclog on a piece, unchanging. Unreal.
He made up unreal.
He's the first to use it in print or on stage with an audience.
That time if understood what the unprefixed meant. No,
I think it takes you a split second
to kind of put that on on the real,
but then suddenly you've got this new concept that there's something real but
Nah, he's taking words that ordinarily are not stuck together.
Things like madcap, ladybird shoving them together,
eye drops to achieve a kind of atomic power.
I saw ball. He did eyeball. Yes.
It's hard to understand how someone could think of that bed.
It seems like it's always been there. If you asked me what his greatest gift is,
he's putting them together into phrases that have stuck in our heads,
so truth will out, truth will out. What's done is done.
I could go on and on. You want to try to go on and on crack of doom.
My favorite dead as a doornail, a dish fit for the gods.
Dog will have his day.
Faint-Hearted fool's paradise forever and a day for going.
Conclusion game is a full game is up Greek to me in a pickle.
In my heart of hearts, in my mind, I heal with kindness.
Believe it or not. Knock, knock. Who's there? Oh,
that's you. Stuff into stitches. Love is blind. What the dickheads.
All's well that ends well.
Something wicked this way comes
and a sorry sight. Wow,
that's a champion. That's fantastic.
How did he create phrases that stick in the mind that make it seem as if they
always existed? Yeah. You're taking out a book.
Thinking of a passage here that is maybe the biggest book I've ever seen.
It was at least 3000 pages. Shakespeare doesn't write a lot about process,
but there are one or two places where he does in a poem called Lucrece in which
a woman is a rake,
Lucrece is rape and she has to write a letter to her husband explaining what
happened to her and she's struggling to define the words in which to do this and
finally she picks up the pen and it shows she prepares to write first hovering
over the paper with a quill conceit and grief and eager combat fight.
What width sits down his bladder straight with will this two curious good.
This plant l much oppressive people at a door. It's wrong. Her inventions,
which shall go before, are we that couplet again,
much like oppressive people at a door from wrong, her inventions,
which shall go before.
If you want to extrapolate from this something that Shakespeare might have
himself experienced. You have a situation with all these ideas up pressing.
It's like a [inaudible]
one of them. Who's getting through that doorway first?
It's a little bit maybe like that experience you might have in a nightmare New
York club where you've got like thousands of people in a tiny space and
everyone's trying to push their way out and I'm like, Chad, let me do the door,
get out of my way. And it's just like this [inaudible]
of images of sound concedes thoughts, ideas, and, and,
and they are providing the pressure that's needed
to do use words.
You know what just makes sense to me, this interpretation now,
not just for Shakespeare, we'd be for anybody.
Certainly the guy we met at the beginning. Ildefonso who'd,
who just learned where it's for the first time. Yeah.
I mean as you move through the world,
if you're sensitive at all and you're observant,
you're going to get filled up with all of these things which you have to express
but can't until you get those words,
then boom,
the door opens. [inaudible]
and thanks to James Shapiro,
Professor at Columbia University whose newest book is contested two will,
who wrote Shakespeare also thanks to our kids,
Louisa CRAs now Stella story and Isaiah Harrison.
And also thanks to the moms that brought them in. Theresa Tripoli,
Carrie Donahue and Patricia Starbuck.
Hello, this is Susan trawler radio lab is funded in part for the Alford,
Katie Sloan Foundation. Charles Burney,
who Radiolab is produced by Wun YC and distributed by NPR.
Hey, this is jad from Radiolab. We're having a, uh,
we're celebrating a little milestone over here at radio lab.
We have been doing this, we making stories for the podcast,
for the radio for 15 years at is 15 years of stories about like,
um, I don't know. The science of morality, the metamorphosis of butterflies,
the legal foundation for the war on terror. All these different stories.
I've been doing it for 15 years.
So check out our latest episode out of the archives and all of our episodes are
available wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is our
words, power of words. So once words into your head,
once they tickle in there and we just explained how that happens sort of then
the, I know they're always there, like, but what if they're not?
What would happen if that who
that throng that is in your head.
Yeah.
What if all of that stuff, whatever's in your head suddenly went
get yanked right out of your head. Hmm. What would be left? Hello.
This got us thinking about a very famous time.
One of the Ted Conferences,
I got the study of the brain talk given by an euro anonymous named Jill bolty.
Is it bolty or [inaudible]? Bowtie Taylor. Yeah.
And all you really need to know is that one morning in December of 1996 Dr.
Taylor woke up and she had,
she had a headache.
I woke up to a pounding pain behind my left eye and it was the kind of pain,
caustic pain that you get when you bite into ice cream.
And it just gripped me and then it released me and it was very unusual for me to
ever experience any kind of of pain. So I thought, okay,
I'll just start my normal routine.
So I got up and I jumped onto my cardio glider,
which is a full body full exercise machine and I'm jamming away on this thing
and I'm realizing that my hands look like primitive claws grasping onto the bar.
And I thought, Whoa, I'm a weird looking thing.
So I get off the machine and I'm standing in my bathroom getting ready to step
into the shower and now I lost my balance and I'm propped up against the wall
and I'm asking myself, what is wrong with me? What is going on?
And in that moment, my right arm went totally paralyzed by my side.
In fact, a blood vessel in the left hemisphere of Jill's brain had
[inaudible] and that part of your brain was starting to shut down and it was the
shutdown that really caught our attention.
In that moment, my brain chatter went totally silent,
just like someone took a remote control and push the mute button.
So here I am in this space and my job and any stress related to my,
my job, it was gone and I felt lighter in my body.
And then all of a sudden my left hemisphere comes back online and it says to me,
hey, I'm having a stroke and we gotta get some help. And I'm going, Oh,
I've got a problem, I've got a problem. So I take, okay, okay I got a problem.
But then I immediately drifted right back out.
And I affectionately refer to this space as la La land. But it was,
I'm just watching my
brain become more and more, uh, um, incapable of functioning.
That is Jill Bolte Taylor herself. Hi Robert. We actually got her into a studio.
Hello. Jad Hello.
Cause we wanted to ask you some questions about that moment when her inner
voices went away.
So let's talk about brain chatter for a moment in the story that we've told so
far, you're still yourself questions. How did that stop it?
On the morning of the stroke,
I was doing this wafting dance between the right hemisphere and the left
hemisphere. So language would come back on.
But once I got to the emergency room and I passed out,
when I woke later that afternoon, I had absolutely no language.
Did you know your name? No. Did you know your address? No.
Did you know about your summer from 1983 no.
You know like my mom is so and so. Any of them? None of it.
I didn't know any of that. Just imagine she's lying in her bed.
Her head is shaved, wrapped in bandages. She's had hours of brain surgeries,
got tubes coming out of her mouth, however knows she's lost her career.
She's lost her language. I lost all my memories and yet she says,
sitting there in that suddenly wordless space
found a peace inside of myself that I had not known before.
I had pure silence inside of my mind. Pure silence.
Pure silence here. Silence. What you know,
not that little voice that that you know.
You wake up in the morning and the first thing your brain says is, Oh man,
the sun is shining. Well, imagine that you don't hear that little voice saying,
man, the sun is shining and you just experience the sun in the shining.
Does. Is this the absence of reflection of any kind?
Is it just central intake and period? Yeah.
Is exactly what it was. It was. It was all of the present moment.
Did you have thoughts? I had joy.
I had a son. I just had children. I had,
I had this magnificent
experience of I'm this collection of these beautiful cells.
I'm organic. I'm this, this origin
Kanick entity. You have a deadhead period by any chance.
You know why I missed that by a few years. But I get a lot of that.
And the other thing that she told us is that lying in that bed without words,
she says she felt connected to things,
to everything in a way that she never had before.
Oh yeah.
I lost all definition of myself in relationship to everything in the external
world.
You mean like you couldn't figure out where you ended [inaudible] how much of
that was was about language? A little part.
A lot. I mean,
well, I would say it was huge languages and ongoing information processing.
It's the constant reminder I am, this is my name,
this is all the data related to me. These are the my likes and my dislikes.
These are my beliefs. I am an individual. I am a single, I'm a solid.
I'm separate from you. This Rudy is,
this may sound to play pin all this on language.
We have run into this idea before a couple of seasons ago. Uh,
Paul Brock's remember him. Yeah, sure.
Neuro-Psychologist you will trust me about myself. I just,
you told me that there is a theory out there which he believes actually that all
a person is in the end, like all the personhood of a person,
the I or the you of a person.
All that is in the end is a story.
A story you tell yourself.
We normally think over when we think about ourselves is really a story.
It's the story of what's happened to that body over time.
I did not have that portion of my language centers that tells a story.
Here is little Jill,
Jill Bolte Taylor climbing the Harvard ladder through language loves deception,
cutting up thing. That language was gone.
I got to essentially become an infant
again. I mean this is the problem here.
What do you mean when you drop out of the ins of yourself or the story of
yourself, then you are left. She says at peace.
I could argue that that's just stranded.
That's stranded in the sunshine with the win in the now.
But I mean it's not like she stayed there. That's true.
Let me a dog in terror if she had, and as she started to recover,
she ran into something kind of interesting,
which sounded to me sorta like what maybe the rats and the babies go through in
the white room.
She would have these disparate thoughts and then go back and stall out.
Like she couldn't bring them together.
Yeah. When, when people would speak to me, I would,
I remembered in pictures. So, um, if somebody would ask me,
who's the president of the United States of America?
This is a huge question.
So for the next several hours I'd be pondering president, president,
president wants the president,
and then I would get a picture in my mind of a president as a leader of a
specific guy. It's, it was actually, it still flashes into my mind. It's,
it's a picture of a, of a silhouette of a male presidential profile.
Like maybe the idea of a president basically.
So that was our president and then I had to figure out a United States then. So
eventually I come up with this map in my mind,
this picture of the United States and then the line drawings.
Now she's got this map,
she's got this silhouette of a guy and she said after hours,
president United States, president United States, and was like, oh my God,
she's still couldn't somehow bring together,
I didn't have the road that I had to travel in order to come up with.
Um, I think it was Clinton at the time. Yeah, it was Clinton at the time. No,
as Jill starts to get better,
this was after eight years of hard work and recovery and the words start to
trickle back. And when they did,
she says that silence that she loved so much got pushed out.
That was one of the sacrifices for me. That was one of the sacrifices.
Wow. Oh Wow. We're doing a, we're doing a language show here at,
you're the Auntie Queen. Our language. So you're like saying mu needs it.
No, no, no, no, no.
But what I am saying is that in order for us to communicate with language,
we pull ourselves away from a different kind of experience.
I do believe that there are times when you need to let your,
your brain chat or be quiet.
But is it fair to say this is a please agree or disagree with this?
I think that words and language and grammar are necessary but not half as good
as wind in my hair as smelling my nose and that old right brain sensual
immediacy.
Yeah. You know, if, um, if I had to choose,
which is essentially what you're saying, if I had to choose, um,
that would be really, really, really tough decision.
[inaudible]
Jill Bolte Taylor is the author of, uh, what's it called?
The book my stroke of insight. Yes. Check our website,
radiolab.org for any details and if you subscribe to our podcast,
there is a bonus video that goes along with this hour and it's pretty great.
I'm Louie [inaudible] calling from Christchurch, New Zealand.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information about learn at www dot [inaudible] dot org
I'm Jad Abumrad, Robert Krulwich, Radiolab,
our topic today where its power of words of language. Okay,
so Nicaragua 1970s that's where our next story starts. You with me?
So imagine you're a kid that's deaf in Nicaragua at this time. Born deaf,
are born deaf, born deaf.
You've always been deaf and you're the only one in your family that's deaf.
So you're in this situation where everybody's talking, their mounts are moving,
you can't hear it and you don't know sign language cause no one's taught you.
There was no deaf school in Nicaragua. There's nothing,
no deaf education of any kind. So if you were this kid,
all you've really got are a couple of gestures, really crew gestures.
You've worked out to talk to your family and friends. But beyond that,
your cutoff, like Ildefonso the guy we met at the beginning of this show,
except in Nicaragua in the 70s there were hundreds,
maybe thousands of these elder fans. Those really? Yeah,
but then everything changes in the late seventies hopes of who was the wife of
the then dictator established a new school for special education.
I think she had someone in her family who had a disability, not deafness,
but the school would include deaf people and that says psychology professor and
Sing Hos was the first cause now instead of deaf kids scattered about,
they were together.
No,
in the same room, there were 50 deaf kids in that first center in class,
preschool to sixth grade. The late seventies
[inaudible]
mean for most of them.
This was the first time they'd ever met another deaf person before the world was
going on around them and everyone was all talking and they were cut off from
that and suddenly for the first time they were all there and they were what was
happening and they were what there was to talk about,
but they didn't have a way of talking.
These are 50 different kids who'd never learned a language and had 50 different
sets of like rudimentary gestures that they used to. Wow.
That must have been, yeah,
like 50 people with 50 different ways to try and ask for breakfast or say they
want to go outside. I mean nothing was shared.
It's not like the teachers were using sign in the classroom.
Everything in the classroom was Spanish, which none of them knew,
copying it into their notebooks.
A lot of it was going right over their heads who at the beginning things were
completely confusing,
but they're riding on the bus for an hour every day and they're playing out of
recess for an hour every day and they're getting together at the park and no one
knows how it happened. Like maybe one of the kids who was very charismatic,
he invented a sign for safe ball,
then told it to another kid who was very socially active and that second kid
then spread the sign. However, it worked over time,
the signs that these 50 kids used started to converge into a common system.
And when you step back from it all, what that means,
they created a language
[inaudible]
they, it's, they didn't just take it from somewhere else.
They couldn't take it from somewhere else.
They created their own. But how unusual is that?
Like this has happened with languages all over the world,
but not while people were watching.
And so you're saying this is the first time we've been able to watch a language
being born? Yeah.
Wow.
And for the last 20 years, that is what Anne has been doing.
She's been going to Nicaragua to that school
and watching [inaudible].
So, um, oh, you want to describe that?
So I may have gotten recording of this, but when you arrive at the school,
but the buses come around,
the kids are all screaming and leaning out the windows and siding to each other
and the kids pile out and they line up in rows on the basketball court that's in
the center of the school yard. And they all sing the national him
[inaudible]
and the deaf kids all sign the national him.
They all have one hand over their heart and sign with the other hand while the
the hearing kids sing it and visited the school for the first time in 1990 about
10 years after it was formed.
She'd been working at the time with a linguist named Judy Kegel studying basic
linguist type stuff. Right.
Trying to figure out how the verbs work and whether they have agreement with
their grammatical objects and along the way her and a collaborator jetty Pires
stumbled into something really surprising about the power of certain words
though to set it up. When she got there the first time and to Nicaragua,
those original 50 kids who'd invented this thing had grown up already and there
were these younger generations of kids coming in behind them,
growing up with the language, using it,
inventing new signs and at a certain point she got curious to just compare the
original signers, the older kids to the younger kids. Yeah.
In terms of how they sign.
So we show everyone this one minute cartoon about this guy who's trying to fly.
He sees a bird flying and he puts all these feathers on his body and clubs up to
the top of a mountain, flaps his arm and jumps out
and fresh is on the ground.
So she showed deaf kids of different generations, this cartoon,
and asked them pretty simply to describe what they saw.
Just describe it and sign described the whole story, the differences.
We're striking first of all. So I'll just show you an example of each.
Your own vaping a movie here.
So this is a first cohort signer talking about.
She got her laptop and showed me some video.
First of this woman air her forties with dark hair and a colorful t-shirt.
She was one of the original signers. And when you see older signers like her,
describe this guy who's trying to fly. It's really spastic.
It's almost like they become the cartoon and she's flapping her hands
essentially. So moving all around,
a lot of full body movements.
She's talking about someone who's moving in a crazy way.
She's going to be moving in a crazy way.
And then she showed me a young kid who was about eight the backwards cat
Sylvester,
and now he talks about the manner when he described the man jumping and then
falling. It was all in the wrist.
All the movement is now in the hand and it's a very stylish,
you know, they're trimming these signs down.
But more to the point there was one thing she noticed that was really
unexpected, had nothing to do with movement,
couldn't help noticing that they, that people,
different people in the community talked about different things in this story.
The older signers tended to describe all the events in this story and only the
events and the younger kids,
they would talk about the guy's feelings that this guy was trying to fly,
wanted to fly, but failed the kid. She says,
just seem to be better at thinking about thinking,
thinking like other people's thinking. So Anne and Jenny decided,
let's take all the different generations of deaf kids, 40 year olds,
30 year olds, 20 year olds, 10 year olds.
Let me test them on how well they can think about thinking.
So what they did was they showed everybody a comic strip different from before.
This one was about two brothers.
There was a big brother who was playing with the train and then little brother
is like wanting to play with the training and the big brothers playing with the
train.
And then the big brother puts it under the bed and goes into the kitchen to eat
a sandwich mean maybe before he goes. He looks at the little brother and says,
Hey, don't touch my train, don't touch it. And then little brother,
while the big brothers out of the room takes the train out and hides it in the
toy box. And then the big brother comes back and the question is,
where's the big brother going to go to find this train?
Is he going to look under the bed or is he going to look in the toy box? Wow.
He's gonna look under the bed. Yup. Because as far as he knows,
that's where he left it. Yeah. He didn't see it moves.
And if you ask kids over the age of five,
most of them would say he's going to look under the bed because that's where he
left it and he doesn't know that it's been moved to the toy box.
But here's the thing. When she asked the older signers, they would say,
oh look in the toy box. Really they would pick the wrong one. These are Pete,
35 year olds. 35 year olds would get this wrong. They would fail this task.
Yeah, seven out of eight she says,
and then all of the younger signers that we worked with past at this point,
she's just confused like why would this be,
why can't the older people pass the simple test, you know,
that involves thinking about someone else's thinking, what's going on here.
And then in a career tour you might have something to do with certain words
because the older signers,
they don't really have that many words for the concept of thinking.
I mean they have mainly just one side pointing at your forehead. Yeah.
Basically you just point at your forehead with your index finger.
By the time you get to the younger kids,
they've got tons of words for thinking things like,
I know something and I know that you don't know it. I know something.
And I know you do know it. They've got assigned for understand, believe,
remember,
forget how many roughly where they're 10 or 12 wow.
So from 30 years we go from just a couple to from like knowing and not knowing.
Right? 12 and somehow that makes all the difference.
She says the more of these think words you've got,
the more you can think. Am I right to say that you're tiptoeing toward that,
but you maybe you don't want to go there all the way. I'm trying to think that,
I guess I don't think it's so simple that you could just go in and say, Hey,
I'm going to teach you 10 signs today and now suddenly you're gonna have better
cognitive capacity.
But you are saying though that the verb think [inaudible] is somehow implicated
in my ability to think about your thinking. Right?
[inaudible]
thinking about thinking,
understanding how other people understand.
That's something that having language makes you better at.
There are certain words she says that don't just give you a name for something.
Somehow they give you access to a concept that would otherwise be really hard to
get or even talk about.
It's really hard to talk about thoughts without the word thoughts
are what is time without the word time. It's a really freaking hard concept.
These words are like bridges.
Somehow they get you to some new mental place that otherwise you'd be cut off
from. But that's sad though. I mean these young kids have something that,
that people who actually invented the language double, but
you went back two years later,
tested the same people and then suddenly some of them were performing a lot
better than they had the two years before on the same kinds of tasks.
Do you mean the older signers? Yeah,
they were passing suddenly some of them were passing. Yeah.
What happened? What happened in the past two years? Yeah.
Those younger kids grew up and started hanging out at the deficits association.
Wait, what? So what had happened in the meeting.
So here's the strange twist of the whole thing.
The Deaf Association is this place where the older signers would hang out. Yeah.
It's a social club. So they played chess, do whatever. Well,
it has certain point. These youngsters start showing up, you know,
cause they've graduated and they want to hang out at the deficits association
too. But they bring with them all of their new mental verbs.
You know all these words for thinking. They start using it with the older kids.
The older kids pick it up. Suddenly these older kids are now passing the test.
So there was learning that took place in adulthood that actually gives them new
insight into other people's thinking and motivation and now they can pass these
tasks. That super. That's the story. It's really cool.
[inaudible]
and [inaudible] is an associate professor of psychology at Barnard College in
New York. The thing, of course you want it, you wonder,
it is a, once you've gotten these, this new facility in you,
there's a lot of literature about this.
My fear lady is about this [inaudible] about this. Yeah.
It's about a woman who learns a proper English and she can no longer be a flower
girl and come in and garden. She's not really, yeah,
I guess it is kind of like this. You want like,
remember that our program began with the story of Ildefonso, right?
Which we heard from
Susan Scholler Ildefonso who is the guy who for 27 years had no language at all.
So you kind of wonder,
I can tell you that like what happened to Ildefonso once he got language, right.
And after that first breakthrough where elephants will realize things have named
Susan ended up leaving for a few years. It was a,
about four years, I think, four or five.
Then she decided to write a book about him. And so I, um,
I went and found him again and he had language and I could ask him all kinds of
questions.
Were you able then to sit down with him and ask him about his life and to really
get the sort of his biography somewhat, somewhat one, um,
area that everyone wants to know his, what
was it like to be languaged list? You know what was going on in his head? Yeah.
And I asked, when I asked, when I asked,
and he starts telling me that was the dark time in his life, learning languages.
It's like the lights went on.
And I tell him what we know about language when we want to know what it's like
not to have language and he doesn't want to talk about it.
But there was a day,
she says when she was writing the book and she met Ildefonso in a restaurant and
there he was sitting with his brother, Mario, who she never met before.
And she quickly learned that Mario also was deaf and that language lists Billy.
So I was shocked and because I was so amazed going,
I can't believe you have a language that's brother. That's when I'm,
when elder finds the son, well let, let me introduce you to some of my friends.
So they get in a car and they drive for awhile. We stop at this apartment.
We were walking to this small little room
and there were these six Mexican men doing this mine routine.
Wait. All of these guys were like Ildefonso used to be, they had no language.
We we're all born deaf and they didn't know that they were deaf and what were
they doing? One man would stand up and he was starting miming.
He would just start acting out a bull fight.
So He'd be the bull and he'd be charging and then you'd be the matador and then
he'd be somebody in the crowd watching. And then he would add a detail.
For example, a house
[inaudible]
and they'd swap. So then another guy would get up to take over the story.
Then they'd start miming, maybe Mac the matador, describe the hat.
But now the second storyteller would add a new detail,
like another person with a pair of glasses or something.
So each one would stand up, take the bull,
fight the same bull fight to a different point and add a detail.
Exactly, exactly. Oh my God. In other words,
I would take him maybe 45 minutes to say,
do you remember the time when we were out the bullfight and this woman did such
and such? It was like drawing a picture.
Well, let me ask you a a pull it all together. Question.
I was about to think that what a language is is a great connector.
But this last story makes me wonder,
these are five men really sharing and connecting on details.
So is the difference that language makes just efficiency or does it effect your
heart or your whole body of I can't tell. I'm not sure anymore.
Well, I'll, I'll give you Ildefonso the answer, which
when I saw him, um, a couple of years later after this incident,
I asked him about his friends and he said he couldn't talk to them anymore.
He wasn't willing to go through that tedious effort of all the miming anymore.
But the interesting thing that he said was,
he can't even think that way anymore.
He said he can't think the way he used to think.
And when I pushed him to ask about what it was like to be languaged lists,
the closest
he ever came to any kind of an answer was exactly that. I don't know.
I don't remember.
I think differently now.
[inaudible]
Susan Sharla is author of the book a Man without words.
Go to radio lab.org for more info. And if you go there,
or if you're subscribed to our broadcast, you'll get this automatically.
But there's a beautiful short film directed by two really talented guys,
will Hoffman and Daniel Mirka Dante, that is all about words.